[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOSH GORDON: Hey, everyone.
Welcome back.
Features are the way you
represent your knowledge
about the world
for the classifier,
and today I'll walk
you through techniques
you can use to represent
your features and utilities
TensorFlow provides to help.
You use a dataset from the
US census as an example,
and the goal is to predict
if someone's income is
greater than $50,000 based
on attributes like their age
and occupation.
The dataset is
stored as a CSV file,
and previously we've seen how to
use the column values directly
as features.
But today we'll use
feature engineering
to transform them into a
more useful representation.
As we go, I'll visualize
what these transformations do
using a tool called Facets,
and you can find a link to it
in the description.
You'll also find complete code
to train a TensorFlow estimator
on this dataset.
OK, let's get started.
Let's begin with a numeric
attribute like age,
and think about how we can
use it to predict income.
Now if you think about how
age correlates with income,
our first intuition is
that as age increases,
usually so does income.
And the simplest way
to represent this
would just be to take
the raw numeric value
and use that as a feature.
Here we're building
a list of features
we use to train the
model, and each of these
is stored as a feature column.
This contains data about
the column from the CSV file
and how to represent it.
Here we'll write a feature that
just uses the raw value of age,
and this string corresponds
to a column in the CSV file.
Now what can go wrong
with this approach?
Well, if we think more
closely about age,
we realize it's not in a linear
relationship with income.
The curve might look
something like this.
It's flat for children, then
increases during working age,
and decreases during retirement.
A linear classifier,
for example,
is unable to capture
this relationship.
That's because it learns a
single weight for each feature.
To make it easier for the
classifier, one thing we can do
is bucket the feature.
And bucketing transforms
a numeric feature
into several
categorical ones based
on the range it falls into,
and each of these new features
indicate whether a person's
age falls into that range.
And now a linear model can
capture the relationship
by learning different
weights for each bucket.
Let's see how this
looks in Facets.
Conveniently,
there's a live demo
that runs in the browser with
our census data preloaded,
and each individual from
the CSV is visualized
as a dot colored by income.
If you click on a dot, you can
see stats about the person.
Now let's bucket
by age, and you can
adjust the number of buckets to
make it more or less granular.
How you choose the number
of buckets is up to you,
and ideally, you'd want to use
your knowledge of the problem
to do this well.
In TensorFlow, we can
create a bucketized feature
by wrapping a numeric
column from the CSV.
And here we're
specifying the number
and the ranges of the
buckets we'd like created.
Once this is done, we can
add the bucketized feature
to the list used
to train our model.
Now let's see how to represent
a categorical feature,
and I'll use the education
column as an example.
Because there are
only a few values,
the best way to represent this
is just use the raw value.
And here we'll create
a feature column
that says education can be a
single value from this list.
Of course, you could also read
the values from a file on disk
rather than writing
them out in code.
Now using the raw value
is the right thing
to do when there are only a
small number of possibilities.
We'll cover the case
where there are thousands
of possibilities in a moment.
First, let's take a look
at feature crossing.
Feature crossing is a way
to create new features that
are combinations
of existing ones,
and these can be especially
helpful to linear classifiers,
which can't model
interactions between features.
Here's what this
looks like in Facets.
I'll take our age
buckets from before
and cross them with education.
Under the hood, you can think
of a true-false feature being
created for each
bucket that tells
the classifier whether
an individual falls
into that range.
Now these buckets
can be informative,
and here we see some groups are
likely to have a high income,
and others low.
In code, using a feature cross
works the same way as before.
We'll cross our age
buckets with education
and add it to the list
of features to use.
A feature cross can generate
many possibilities quickly,
which is why they
are often represented
under the hood with a hash.
A hashed feature column is one
way to efficiently represent
a categorical feature
with a large vocabulary.
More importantly,
you can use these
as a way to make
your data easier
to work with because
they free you from having
to provide a vocabulary list.
In this example, we'll
represent the occupation column
from our CSV file
by using a hash
with 1,000 possible values.
Notice we don't have to
provide a vocabulary list,
and to avoid collisions,
I've set the hash size
so it's larger than the number
of items in the vocabulary.
Here's how this
works under the hood.
Normally, a categorical
feature is represented
as a one hot encoding.
That means there's one bit
for each possible value
in the vocabulary.
And we can create a lookup
because we know the vocabulary
list in advance.
Now if we don't
know the vocab, we
can use a hash function to
compute the bit automatically.
The downside is there
could be collisions,
meaning different items are
mapped to the same value.
Hashes can also be used
to limit memory usage
at the cost of adding some
noise to your training data.
If you have a large
vocabulary, it
can be memory intensive
to use that as input
to a neural network.
A hashed column can
be used to limit
the maximum number
of possibilities,
but I prefer them
simply as a tool
to save you programming time.
Finally, I'd like to
mention embeddings,
and these can be less intuitive
than the other techniques,
but they're a powerful way
to work with categorical data
in a deep learning setting.
You can think of an embedding
as a vector that represents
the meaning of a word.
And we can visualize a
dataset of word embeddings
using the TensorFlow
Embedding Projector,
and there's an online demo you
can find in the description.
Here we're looking at a dataset
of 10,000 words, each of which
is represented by a vector
with many dimensions,
projected down to 3D
so we can see them.
You can search for words
in the box to the right.
And if you experiment
a bit, you'll
find similar words are
often close together.
For example, all of the words
in this cluster are cities.
What's neat about
embeddings is that they're
learned automatically in the
process of training a DNN.
And to make that happen,
all you need to do
is write an embedding column.
Here we'll create an
embedding for education
with 10 dimensions.
Now embeddings are helpful if
you have a categorical column
with a large
vocabulary and you want
to compress the representation
so the classifier learns
general concepts
rather than memorizing
the meaning of specific words.
For example, imagine
if the census data
had a column called job title.
There are thousands
of different jobs,
and an embedding could be used
to help your classifier learn
that words like programmer
and software engineer
often mean the same thing.
OK, hope this was
a helpful intro,
and thinking about how to
represent your features
is one of the most
important contributions
you can make to a machine
learning experiment.
Feature columns are
great because they
let you experiment with
different representations
in code and make advanced
features like embeddings
accessible.
As a next step,
I'd recommend you
try the code in the description
and see if you can modify it
for a problem you care about.
Thanks for watching everyone,
and I'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]